welcome to episode 3 of my book writing
journey today I want to talk about
design design matters not just the
design of you know your book and what
you're writing but everything in your
life right the design of your products
and services a design of your website
the design of your environment design of
your office your space your desk how
things look matter they have an impact
on how you feel and it's important that
you design things that that means
something to you in a positive way and
so how does this relate to my book as
part of the process of getting a deal
with a publisher I had to create a
proposal in the proposal that I made was
very different than the proposal it
actually got submitted what my team
wanted to do my my agent wanted to do
was put it in a way that they were used
to seeing you know I have very different
views on how things should be and how my
book is gonna get released I very
different views and what most
traditional books look like and I wanted
to incorporate that into proposal and my
agent advised me against it saying you
know they're used to seeing things a
certain way and we want to present it in
a certain way or give you the biggest
change of getting a book deal and and so
I you know I went back and forth and at
the end of the day I decided you know
what I'm gonna I'm going to trust in my
agent he's led me to positive places so
far so I'm going to trust in His wisdom
and guidance and he said once you get a
deal with the agent then you can make it
look like whatever you want and so we
made this proposal and it was funny
because they started asking me for more
and more information to add to the page
and I refuse to edit their Google Doc my
setup a google doc and I refuse to edit
it because I didn't like how it was
designed it wasn't designed how we
design it and when I looked at it I
didn't get inspired right like I
couldn't write it hurt me to write in
their design and when I write with my
design the fonts and the spacing and the
layout and maybe I sound really anal
right now but when I when I write with
my design I'm I'm in a positive place I
feel happier I'm more in my flow and so
design matters and and you know creating
an environment that you've designed you
know what is your office look like you
know
when I right outside for example use a
different energy that's a different
design than when I'm inside when I right
on the floor on the on where I had my
first video it's a different kind of
feel than other places and so instead of
just being reactionary I'd encourage you
to design things on purpose it's
starting to rain so I gotta I gotta get
to the Q&A quick let's get to the
questions you guys asked crap stuff
wrote in to say grid video by the way
what is the status of the book I want to
purchase one today book is not ready
friend crap stuff it is going to be I
want to give a timeline it's part of the
contract working it out but I'm working
on it you can follow along in the series
next dirt patch Evan I love stickman in
the background that was Hayden in my
last video but on topic I'm trying to
write an e-book and feel like my biggest
issue is when to stop picking at it and
allow it to be finished you know that's
a tough thing it's such a few
detail-oriented and you want to be
perfect i would say i would assign
specific time to it like i would say
assign specific times in the week so
like sunday morning you're working on it
or friday afternoon you're working on it
or multiple times a week you're working
on it and don't just have it something
that every now and then you pick at it
because in you never got to get it done
so i would pick a time during the week
figure out how much time you need to
write it for me i'm doing tuesdays and
fridays mostly what I'm doing doing the
books and that helps the other thing
that house is having a deadline when
it's imposed on you and other people
right so I'm working with a publisher
we're working on a tentative deadline
i'm waiting for the official agreement
that's a that's a gun to the head right
like i got to get it done for that time
and so if you commit to somebody else to
have it done by a certain time you're
more likely to follow through and i
think that'll light a fire a little bit
unto you to make you want to do it
faster next up Lucy who asked a bunch of
question they'll just go rapid fire
through them one I'd like to write a
book how do I find the right publisher
my process was a little bit different um
I went to an agent right my agent I have
a talent agent who books gigs for me and
corporate deals and that kind of stuff
and he introduced me to a literary agent
and the literary agent then set up all
the deals with the publishers and we set
up kind of a meet-and-greet where I talk
to I don't know six diff
publisher seven different publishers the
proposal went out to a lot of them I had
phone calls with about six or seven of
them and then three of them wrote back
with with bids and it ended up being a
bidding war one going against the other
kind of like a hot real estate market
and my initial offer from the publisher
i went with ended up almost doubling and
so i really value their the wisdom and
leadership of my agents to help guide me
through that process next it is raining
it is raining I gotta go fast is it
necessary to get an agent to get your
work out there uh I think if you want to
get a good price and you want to get a
good contract you're probably better off
getting an agent just like you could
sell your house yourself but you got to
do a lot of research you could be your
own agent and I had you know I had
publishers coming to me before I started
writing the book before I ever wanted to
write a book but they weren't the top
publishers I didn't have those
connections in encode if I could I have
done it myself probably would have taken
enormous amounts of time absolutely
could I've been able to line up you know
six seven people to have interviews on
two days and then have a bidding war
probably not by myself you know you have
to have the right connections for that
so literally I had one I believe was
like a friday where had three calls and
then a monday or tuesday the next week
that I have other for calls and it was
just all back to back to back to back
and everybody knows that you know the
other guys are in on it and that's what
ended up creating the bidding war and
could I have done that myself probably
not could I have gotten a book deal
absolutely could have gotten the book
deal I wanted to probably not so that's
my answer next boom boom boom when
writing my mind starts with one topic
then at mushrooms and derails or unknown
places this happens on a regular if it's
all relevant but not structured any tips
on how do you keep on topic when writing
my issue in writing is I have a hard
time seeing the big picture and a little
picture at the same time I can either
see big picture and for me big picture
is plotting out what's going to be in
each chapter what's going to be in each
section what's the structure going to be
and just seeing everything as a big hole
uh as a whole instead of like a hole
that you go through but but then when I
actually get to writing I have to be
very narrow and very focused so like I'm
going to write this page lay on this
topic in this page on this topic and it
I have a hard time jumping between the
two that switching the hurts my head and
produces crap content for me so I find I
have to have like a day where I'm
working on the bigger picture stuff and
then multiple days where I'm working on
the actual delivery and the you know in
the business I guess kind of analogy so
what I find helpful maybe you can apply
the same thing for your book is spend
the time to plan it out properly at the
start you know plan out what chapters
going to go where how are you going to
write it how it's going to flow design
it and take a day to do that and then
and then have another day where your
writing and if other ideas come to you
what I do is I just sent myself an email
any idea for a new chapter new way new
place I want to take it I send myself an
email and then when it comes down to the
day of my planning design you know day
the big picture day then I look at that
and see where I can fit it in I I think
that's natural like I get tons of ideas
when I'm shopping when I'm sleeping
while when I'm you know lying in bed
when I'm out and about that's when
you're going to get a lot of creative
ideas and so I find just emailing it to
get it out of my head and into my inbox
and then I have a set time to be able to
deal with that I find that that really
helps me and the last question from her
from Lucy was your son is so cute that's
great thank you I agree ah he is out
right now but he had a lot of fun on the
video last week it is raining like crazy
so I'm going to stop and if you guys
have any questions that you want me to
answer for you about my book or the book
writing process how to write a book any
of that stuff leave it below and I'll do
my best to respond thank you guys so
much for watching I'm enjoying this
series so I'll see where it goes take
care of continue to believe I'll see you
soon ok I gotta get out of here holy cow
it's raining how you doing babe you're
coming in you want to be in my video
Nina's checking out her greenhouse it's
raining you got to [ __ ] inside [ __ ] how's
the greenhouse doing
yeah you're in the video we're going
inside together ah what are you doing
dhoni doesn't make it fun okay well good
here we go Toby talk to you next week